[Music]
every day I look more and more insane
right it looked like some kind of porn
mustache do you like it Marcia no you
don't like this this looks so good
a lot of girls would die to look like
this I mean to have a boyfriend that
looks like that today's election day
which means that by the time you're
watching this you've know who won that
became the next president I vote for
Hillary Clinton Stan he always lands
perfectly
[Music]
I just realized I can't see me anyway I
go into the gym now and I'm in a pretty
[ __ ] mood I'm not gonna lie I'm pretty
[ __ ] annoyed but usually be going to
the gym puts me in a good mood so we'll
see in three two one
holy [ __ ] I feel a lot better and they
expect that that was a great [ __ ]
work here what do you say Trump you know
what whatever happens tonight whoever
wins this Trump is gonna burn oh yeah
[Music]
oh my god where did it go I feel better
I shame yeah you didn't like the
mustache huh well if you guys like the
mustache you know whose fault it is
you should have a mustache okay
that's true she is you like this you're
like this what
all right now we're going to stand a mug
because Marzia it's having a lunch
meeting but I'm coming along and she's
really happy about it
[Music]
and a bird
oh my god it's bird above head I love
body bar to bar bar to bow
it's that sexual harassment well I guess
not
by burnable so we're gonna go to k-town
now which is Koreatown there's a bunch
of cool stuff that I'm really excited to
check it out so let's go tonight Trump
will be sacrificed GABA couldn't be more
excited I got a package I wonder it from
crazy fans unexpected such fast delivery
oh this gonna be perfect for Trump so
you can shoot fireballs with this that's
so cool
I saw it online and I'm like I gotta buy
it you can shoot fireballs with your
hands I gotta try that tonight I gotta
try that tonight
come on vital use proper care and watch
instructional video failure to do so may
result in personal injury ah let's get
this show on the road my weed rolling
skills are not the best that's not what
I'm doing a promise I don't smoke
all right stand clear cuz it's about to
pop you ready yeah your family mm-hmm
well I guess I gotta charge Brad
get in the car get in the vehicle that's
his [ __ ] boy
keep going damn you fast boy you run
real fast hey that's a sonic steamer
dude a little bit a little dead dead
dead yeah you're gonna run into trouble
there boy
we're in k-town I'm told there's a lot
of gangs here we have no idea what we're
doing but we're the sweets so they
better watch out
that's g-dragon it's my favorite you
wanna go when I was when she came on so
no just stop saying I'm inviting me oh
thanks
it's the real [ __ ] she's so good you
really want to you know if you want your
girlfriend you're all alone put on this
she's all day she's all day don't tell
my son or should I win I think Freddy is
the coolest come on
there ya go buddy come on foxy get him
give me that Fox oh my god not even
gonna let not even looking
[Music]
yeah did it oh we both bought beyblades
and we agree that the winner loses a
strike here we go you ready to be playin
good I'm gonna do my babe Lee's gonna
destroy your beyblade
oh no my baby's gonna finish my movie
all right three job knotted replay I
think I'm gonna win I'm not gonna get it
no come on beyblade
come on give me that darlin what do you
do you Dutch fun no no I'm not your babe
babe babe babe the wall ain't never
stopped spinning all that money and the
strike you get strike bill music Lee
Lewis won
you guessed right no my control Susan
you loose one hell yeah yeah and we
agree that the winner loses a strike my
favorite ever starts my breathing never
stops my BB nippers
you're even know how to assemble a
beyblade you put it for you go home
[Music]
you
I'll bet it's good reminds me of when I
was a kid
jump fun fact I've done an eagle you
sponsoring
[Music]
okay so tonight is election night no one
really knows who's gonna win so we
decided that you will lose a strike if
you just know who's gonna win but you
gained a strike if you lose but you gain
a striker Bulow's yeah I am go I'm gonna
go
I think Hillary's gonna win it you've
got Hillary yeah
I was Hillary - oh man that means I have
to go from yeah ha ha you know what I'm
losing already take your chance better
now for the record I agree with and
would vote for Trump anyway so I'm gonna
go we go with my boy good man
now let's say I'm on fire ok should work
now I'm really scared here we go whoo
cheap you see that hey Michael you want
to shake my hand - whoa that was cool
Trump oh look it Hey oh damn it come on
man oh whoa oh [ __ ] no whoa whoa got him
whoa wanna burn Trump
come on I'm trying buddy let's just be
clear that no matter if it's Trump or
Hillary I would still burn the pinata
and I didn't get the pinata all right I
don't care
now I'm to burn from which whoa Donald
Trump Donald Trump this trap is on fire
this trap is our fire the Trump the
Trump the Trump is on fire we don't need
no water let the Trump doesn't matter
who wins as long as I don't get a strike
who won Trump
in North Carolina Lee invested
look-alike session we going on for wait
too long
whoa he looks insane look at him he
looks like Dolph waiter wait so who's
winning the election from Trump is
winning know maybe cold seriously what
looks like you boys are getting some
strikes he's got these real favorites
eyes are really close to his inside the
skull not strike buddy no that's a sexy
strike boy how do you feel
one step closer to a tattoo hey you hear
a strike in Georgia no this can't be
happening my boy oh my I'm so upset
about it wait Trump won I don't care
there's Toblerone here I'm talking to my
table their own stop stop your man
spreading those legit terrifying from my
angle Diskin face casa well that's
another day of Barbra who won the
election I don't know we're gonna have
to see there's probably gonna be riots
and [ __ ] anyway but I hope you're not
enjoyed another day sharing it with you
was fun please leave a like if you
enjoyed this episode it really helps out
a lot and I really appreciate it
share Barta boat with your friends
I'll see you bros
[Music]